صحيح في هذه اللحظات وصلت بعض المساعدات
الطبيه في هذه البدايه دعينا نركز على هذه
اللقطه ووصول وفد من الامم المتحده ووصول
جزء من شاحنه وليس شاحنه كامله هذه
الشاحنه كانت تحمل وتقل ثلاث مشاطيح من
الادويه والمستلزمات الصحيه وفق مصادر
طبيه انها مستلزمات طبيه بسيطه حتى هذه
اللحظه وهي وفق الطلب الذي طلب من
المستشفى لكن منظمه الصحه العالميه وفرت
الجزء البسيط من هذه الادويه وهذه
المستلزمات الصحيه التي لا تكفي لاي من
المقومات التي يحتاجها القطاع الصحي هذه
الشاحنه وصلت قبل لحظات افرغت بسرعه كبيره
جدا وتجول الوفد المرافق لهذه الشاحنه
الان داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي ليستطلع
احداث المستشفى ويستطلع حالات الجرحى
ويعرف الحاله صحيه لينقل الرساله التي
ارسل من اجلها هو نقل الادويه بالاضافه
الى استطلاع داخل المستشفى عن حال الجرحى
وحال النازحين في هذا المكان لكن لا زالت
الحاله ماساويه في داخل هذا المستشفى عدد
كبير من النازحين كما تشاهدون يعني في هذه
الصوره وعدد كبير جدا من الجرحى ايضا في
داخل المستشفى لكن ننتظر المصادر الطبيه
حتى ت تحدث بشكل اوضح عن المستلزمات التي
وصلت وتطلعنا بشكل اكبر على التفاصيل التي
ارسلت من اجلها هذه هذا الوفد علما ان هذه
المره الاولى التي تصل بها المساعدات
الطبيه بعد 20 يوما من توقف المساعدات
الطبيه في اخر مره دخلت المساعدات الى
مدينه غزه او شمال وادي قطاع غزه في ال 27
من نوفمبر
2711 وصلت الى شمال وادي قطاع غزه اليوم
تصل المساعدات الطبيه فقط دون اي مساعدات
غذائيه دون مياه دون ال الاحتياجات
اللازمه معلبات دقيق الاحتياجات الرئيسيه
التي هي في الاساس لسد حاجه الناس في
المناطق الجنوبيه بعد 70 يوما 72 يوما من
الحرب تصل المساعدات الطبيه للمره الثانيه
فقط وفي هذه المره تصل شاحنه بسيطه فقط
محمله بالادويه ووفق المصادر الطبيه ان
هذه الشاحنه هي تحمل فقط المعدات البسيطه
وليس ما يحتاجه المشفى بشكل كبير من عجز
في المعدات الطبيه اها